you know i'm really torn about that like
um
maybe you can help have you seen the
movie whiplash
so it's uh i would say from an
outsider's perspective
people should watch it i guess jazz band
it's a movie about a drummer and uh the
instructor
and he it's a basically i would say from
the outsider's perspective it's a toxic
relationship
but he's really the coach whatever we
call him
pushes the the musician the drummer
to his limits like to where
he just feels like um emotionally
it's a it looks like a toxic
relationship but it's one that
ultimately is very
productive for the improvement of the
musician
i have the same like in my own
experience i had um
i got a chance to train a couple places
regularly and so one of my coaches
uh who is a great human being a lot of
people love him
but when i was a blue belt he was
pushing me a lot for competition
and every time i step on the mat i was
uh
anxious and almost afraid of training
because of like the places i'm gonna
have to go
and then the i can't
i don't know what's good or bad because
i think
i've become a better person because of
that experience like i needed that
and on the flip side like the place i
got my
black belt from balance studios is i
remember
also a blue belt the coach sitting down
and i was going to competition and he
saw something in me
where he said you know
like good luck but win or lose
we always love you like i i
re i remember that because i really
needed that at that time like i was
putting so much pressure on myself
like i'm not an actual professional
competitor
you know i just competed like i'm a pg
student like
but like it was clearly having a
psychological effect on me
and that's what a great coach does it's
like
you know it's like life is more
important than jiu-jitsu
since it's bigger so they find
you use jiu-jitsu when you need it to
grow as a person
and when it overwhelms you you you have
to pull that person out like look at the
bigger picture always look at the bigger
picture
it's fascinating and i don't know what
to make of it i don't think i would have
it any other way
is both the anxiety and the and the love
yeah i think that i couldn't that's a
really interesting thing that you're
describing that
i i guess it kind of brings me back to a
lot of the other things we've been
discussing is
just almost like the the reciprocal
nature of everything where
no pressure that's great everyone's
happy all the time it's either i mean
let's uh use an example of sci-fi movies
to say the matrix which of course the
first one was amazing and then each
subsequent movie made the series worse
but um but basically i'm working on a
new one by the way yeah i've heard we'll
see i was hoping for the best
but um but basically uh you know i'd say
hey we started with our first initial
world agent smith says to neo he's like
our first world
was a utopia where everyone was happy
and nothing ever went wrong it's like
your primitive
cerebrum rejected it and i think that
there's
obviously i mean what do i think but i
guess well i'm here so i might as well
say what i think
um i guess uh you know
great things are fantastic a kind
gentle place is fantastic and this is
again why i love dune because i think
dune does such a great job of expressing
frank herbert does such a great job of
expressing again the reciprocal nature
of these ideas
you know look at uh look at sparta for
instance or at least what i understand
sparta from the reading and also
watching 300. um
uh you know and reading wikipedia and
reading the wikipedia article about the
movie
not the place um but uh it's um
that's a hard brutal place and
that was their benefit to that like
absolutely was their drawback to that
absolutely is it sustainable i should i
would think probably not
um i mean granted it hasn't sustained
but i mean that type of a
of a thing it burns too hot almost and
it uh
it it destroys the host at a certain
point and you know i guess that that
type of unforgiving nature
but entirely entirely permissive has its
own
issues and i guess coming back to your
what your description of like describing
a toxic relationship is a very
dangerous and tricky thing because it's
almost like uh it's like bird's eye view
me
it's what you know you see let's say a
husband and wife arguing and you're like
all right well
sort of somebody hitting somebody i need
to keep myself out of this because i
have no idea
what i'm seeing something but i don't
know what's going on or why specifically
and again short of it going to a place
that's that just out out of bounds
i don't know who's right here i don't
know who's wrong and i don't know what
phase of this
things are in so i i guess long term
what's good for
yeah both people right it's dangerous
for so if i want to put my finger on the
scale i can understand the desire to do
i'm like hey guys let's break it up
yeah but and that may be the right thing
at the time but at the same time i'm not
sure so i think back to all of the times
that
you know that like you mentioned your
coach pushing you when it's very very
hard
and then other times going like hey
let's put in perspective here
i think that's an interesting thing for
high performance and i think that we're
seeing that again societally
you know now or at least maybe that just
pops up on my internet feed periodically
um but coaches shouldn't be allowed to
do this or yell at this person to yell
at that person like well
have you ever been go to a boxing gym
it's not a commercial entity not really
like a real box not la boxing not a ufc
gym
like a real place you're going to see
what things are like when it's entirely
performance-based go to wrestling room
at a high level
you know again there's there's left and
right limits and there are such things
obviously as abuse of course but and
that should never be tolerated
but it's not a commercial entity
i don't need to be sweet to you if
you're if you're screwing up if you're
dropping the ball and in fact
recognizing that i'm not
doing you a favor or the team a favor by
by
being permissive of that type of
behavior i think is important everything
in its context and at its time
is important and i guess i can think
again at the times that i've been on put
put or had put on me like a great deal
of pressure
to do x y as a year to succeed um or to
push for success and
i can't look back fondly enough on those
times
they were tough at the time but without
that i'm not sitting here without that
i don't go from growing up in a very
nice family in the suburbs to fighting
at the highest level in jiu jitsu
nogi and now in mixed martial arts
starting a career at age 27.
you know i don't it just doesn't happen
because people generally speaking from
that
background don't get pushed hard enough
physically to be able to make that
transition
and that has benefits and it has
drawbacks you know when you stare into
the abyss it stares back and i think
that that's an important thing to
understand
you know you stare long enough you you
can become something that you don't
that you would be sorry that you did you
don't look enough and you don't have
perspective either
you know and i i think that that's an
interesting thing i can speak to someone
who's relative to being
someone who's relatively articulate and
reasonably i try to be reasonable
but you know i'll say inspiring if
people get crazy with me they get a
warning
and then i'mma crack them and what did
they expect
oh they hear the guy on an interview
but who did they think they were meeting
because there's also the guy in the ring
you